okay so let's talk about open problems
future all of that right so I have a
bunch of things here and I think we
should be able to hit all but let's
start from the beginning
so we are going to talk about several of
these aspects here as you can see you
know a lot of these areas are still
active research directions including
coming up with new postdoc explanation
methods with sort of uh you know levate
or address some of the limitations that
we have talked about right so we'll go
in this order and try to cover each of
these pieces one by one so the first
also this uh the first one is you know
new methods for more reliable post-hoc
explanations right not surprising
because we are seeing there are all
these problems with existing methods
what do we do okay
all right uh so
we have seen that there are several
limitations in the behavior of existing
methods for example they are unstable
inconsistent fragile not faithful while
there are already different attempts to
address some of these limitations there
is definitely more work that is needed
right so for example I'm going to touch
upon one recent approach that we had
which gained a lot of traction which
helps address some of the classic issues
with these postdoc explanation methods
not all of them some of them so we
talked about you know methods such as
lime being unstable and we also talked
about this issue of consistency which is
you know the same method run on the same
point can generate drastically different
explanations and that is particularly
true when the number of perturbations
you're using is small right so we
discussed this a little bit that if it's
the problem with having too few
perturbations what is the optimal number
of perturbations can we just use a very
long large number of perturbations right
the issue with using very large number
of perturbations is again it's a
computational challenge in practice
because especially if you are looking at
very complex models like Inception net
or s net and so on querying these models
for labels repeatedly for a lot of
points you know because each time you
generate a perturbation you go and take
the label from the model and if you keep
doing this repeatedly for a large number
of perturbations for each point in the
data set this becomes very
computationally intensive very fast
right so because of that you can't just
apply the principle of just put a large
number of perturbations there and you'll
be done so a more senior approach would
be to actually determine what is the
minimum number of perturbations required
to get to that sort of converged
explanation okay
uh so what we do is this this kind of
idea or paper on explanations with some
uncertainty guarantees so we consider
Bayesian versions of lime and shap and
the reason why this is actually better
than just having Point estimates of
future importances is it at least tells
you what is the confidence interval or
the uncertainty interval associated with
your explanations this is particularly
important because as we have seen there
are not exactly very authoritative
metrics for things like faithfulness I
mean there are ways in which we
discussed how they can be approached and
you know you can compare to explanations
and so on given that that piece is not
completely set in the literature yet
this kind of having some estimates of
uncertainty instead of giving one point
estimate one point value for each
feature and say this is the importance
if we can say how uncertain the
algorithm is about this feature
importance that can be very valuable
right and this also kind of helps us
consolidate like for example there was a
nice point about if you change the
number of perturbations your explanation
changes right and as a end user or even
as a designer it makes no sense to me if
I see two different explanations and I
don't know how to consolidate which one
is right all of that but once you put
uncertainty into the picture if I run
lime with say 100 perturbations versus
running lime with 2000 perturbations so
clearly the mean has changed but you
know the uncertainty interval is still
being captured right so with lesser
number of perturbations I'm seeing that
there is more uncertainty with larger
number of perturbations I'm seeing that
there is less uncertainty but at least
it's captured by this window these are
not conflicting things right so that is
helpful for me to sort of consolidate
what is happening here okay what we do
here is essentially this kind of a
Bayesian locally weighted regression so
we make the entire setup of lime
Bayesian pretty much and we make it in
such a way that you don't have to use
methods like sampling or variation
inference or anything which is
computationally intensive we can compute
all the parameters in closed form and
the means of these approaches also turn
out to be the estimates that lime or
shap will output in expectation okay so
there's the clear parallel and we are
able to add an uncertainty interval on
top of it and using some of these
Bayesian Frameworks that we have or the
details of this framework we also
developed like some theory for like
estimating the required number of
perturbations that will help us achieve
user defined levels of confidence so for
example if a user says I need an
explanation where the true feature
importance lies within plus or minus 0.5
of your estimated feature importance
with 95 confidence interval if that's
the requirement of a user we can take
those and then give you a number n which
is the number of perturbations that you
need to use with you know baseline or
base shape in order to give this
guarantee on the uncertainty of the
feature importance values okay and we
can also do more tweaks in this kind of
a setting because we are capturing
uncertainty for example instead of you
know sort of just taking random
perturbations which is what these
approaches do typically we can be sort
of more intelligent about it and say
we'll only choose those points that the
learning algorithm is most uncertain
about because we are capturing the
uncertainty now right and only on those
points we'll ask the underlying models
for labels for other points which your
learning algorithm is already certain
about we don't need to query this
complex model and waste compute in that
okay
so yeah that adds to the efficiency so
in some sense this whole approach allows
us to construct explanations with uh
user-defined levels of confidence in an
efficient manner
okay so other questions that would be
interesting to explore in this kind of a
context is can we construct post-hoc
explanations that are probably robbers
to various adverse serial attacks
discussed earlier right so what the
previous approach that I talked about is
fixing is some pieces you know some of
the consistency issues and so on uh but
can we now develop new methods or new
explanations that are probably robbers
to some of the adversarial attacks we
discussed or can we construct post-hoc
explanations that can simultaneously
guarantee several of the properties that
we discussed which is whether it's
fairness or faithfulness or stability
and so on there are no answers for these
questions at this time okay
all right
uh let's talk about what are some you
know problems that are open in terms of
theoretical analysis so we actually
discussed some of the recent theoretical
results just like a few minutes back
despite some of those preliminary
attempts of course there are huge gaps
there is lot more to do for example can
we characterize the conditions under
which post hoc explanation method
unsuccessfully or successfully captures
the behavior of the underlying model
right uh currently there are not very
good answers for this but like can we
put a precise characterization on when
they can actually capture the underlying
model or not with respect to different
Notions of what exactly it means to
capture the behavior of an underlying
model right and given the properties of
the underlying model data distribution
can be theoretically determined which
explanation method should be employed
right so some of our recent work is
going along these directions uh but you
know there's it's no way sort of a
solution to these kinds of big questions
but it's interesting to sort of think
about these kinds of questions right and
can we theoretically analyze the nature
of the prototypes and attention weights
learned by Deep knits with added layers
when are these meaningful when are they
spurious again there are no answers
these are all big open problems and you
know they're also not easy problems in
some sense but definitely worth explore
sorry
okay so let's talk a little bit about
what are some other open questions in
empirical evaluation of the correctness
and utility of model interpretations
right so we actually spent quite a bit
of time discussing some of the empirical
results and Analysis of correctness and
utility in spite of all that as we
briefly talked about earlier there is no
clear characterization of which methods
if any are correct or useful under what
conditions right uh again this is
something that I think hopefully as the
field also evolves we come up with like
a certain systematic set of evaluations
benchmarks standard practices for doing
user studies and then we'll be able to
come up with more clearer answers but
currently if you say oh when does or
like you know Islam explanation or are
Lyme explanations helpful to doctors in
this
you know the dancer is we really don't
know right
um and there is actually even lesser
work I'm sure some of you have noticed
this but there is even lesser work on
the empirical analysis of the
correctness or utility of
interpretations generated by inherently
interpretable models right post talk
explanations there has been a huge sort
of you know uh like area that has formed
around it but inherently interpretable
models there is even less work for
example our prototypes generated by
adding these layers even meaningful we
don't know right can they be leveraged
in any real world applications what
about attention weights there are
absolutely no studies to answer any of
these questions
okay
all right
so the next piece is characterizing the
similarities and differences we talked
about how a lot of these methods
actually disagree with each other in
terms of the outputs they produce right
uh but let's see what are some open
problems to look at there okay
so several post talk explanation methods
exist which are employing diverse
algorithms diverse definitions of what
even is an explanation right some are
saying you know rules is an explanation
others are saying importances are
explanations and so on so under what
conditions do these methods are a subset
of these Methods at least
generate similar outputs right so we
want to try and quantify that uh and
that will also help us understand when
will they give you similar outputs when
will they give you different outputs
that understanding is also important for
us to sort of both build better methods
and like basically get to a point of
where we know a bit more than what we
know about explanation methods currently
right and there are multiple
interpretable models which output you
know natural synthetic prototypes when
are these actually generating similar
prototypes and why and what conditions
are they generating similar prototypes
when are they going to generate
different prototypes again we don't know
right so clearly I think that's whole
Space of you know making models
interpretable by adding layers of
prototypes or attentions is like there's
a huge void in terms of what can we say
theoretically at all or you know even
empirical analysis honest
okay and then the next piece is so today
I think in this discussion we have
extensively covered predictive models
specifically focusing on classification
now what do we do about going Beyond
classification right I think our
immediate reaction as well
classification is already messy enough
so what can we do Beyond it but I think
there is no harm in hoping and dreaming
anytime uh so yeah now you know with
with sort of this craziness of more and
more complex models kicking in into full
force and uh you know high gear so now
we have all these large language models
Foundation models like what does it even
mean to think of interpretability there
right so what's even feasible there
those are also like just open questions
that nobody has good answers for right
and there's also already active work on
interpretability and reinforcement
learning in graph neural networks uh so
however there is very little research on
analyzing the correctness or utility of
explanations in these contexts So
currently there are some approaches laid
out there but like nobody really knows
if they're doing the right thing if
they're right when are they right all of
that
okay so given that these primitive
interpretable models or post-hoc
explanations themselves suffer from so
many limitations how do we ensure that
when we try and construct explanations
for more complex models those are
probably going to be more reliable and
they're not suffering from all these
limitations that we have just spent the
last couple of hours talking
right okay so another sort of these
three are kind of related but
essentially uh exploring intersections
between interpretability and other key
pillars of this broader area of
trustworthy machine learning like
robustness or fairness or privacy is
also very important because there are
implications of interpretability on
these properties and there are also
implications of these properties on
interpretability so how to sort of think
about that that's also like a space
where there are lots of interesting open
problems okay so for example if we think
about robustness uh you know we'll sort
of like we can say are inherently
interpretable models with these
prototype or attention layers more
robust than those without these layers
right if so why uh are they giving I
think you know earlier we were
discussing with Anthony that are these
layers actually adding some kind of
regularization if so can they improve
robustness almost as side effect okay
again we don't know so that's a problem
up for exploration and are there any
inherent trade-offs between certain
kinds of model interpretability and
model robustness or do these aspects
always kind of try and reinforce each
other again an open question uh so some
of our recent work actually shows
theoretically and empirically that
counterfactual explanation generation
algorithms actually outputted were
serial examples so this is pretty
interesting because essentially as we
talked about earlier a lot of these
algorithms are basically saying take a
point put a bit slightly get it across
the boundary and that is your
counterfaction right but that's also
kind of what a lot of adversarial
example approaches do
okay that's one part of it but there is
the other part of it which is a lot of
machine Learning Community is trying to
build adversarially robust models uh
which is they're trying to eliminate
adversarial examples uh so now what does
this mean for counterfactual
explanations or recourses so where does
the boundary of or where does the end of
count of actual explanations happen and
where does the beginning of adversary
examples happen right so what is the
boundary between those two that's also
quite blurry so I think there's a huge
sort of set of research problems there
okay so with respect to model fairness
uh in fact this is yet another
interesting piece oftentimes when people
motivate model interpretations are
explanations they think of it as oh
explanations can help unearth all these
you know unfairness or biases in models
right uh so that's like a motivation
that's often used in the introductions
of a lot of papers however there is not
a whole lot of empirical or theoretical
research which actually kind of touches
upon this topic forget demonstrating it
like you know we don't even have studies
that sort of try to see if this is
happening right uh so definitely
conducting more empirical evaluations
and user studies along these lines to
determine how interpretations and
explanations can complement statistical
Notions of fairness in identifying
biases is important because there are
already there's already a bunch of
literature on fairness but that
literature focuses on how to sort of
quantify statistically what unfairness
looks like the argument for explanations
is when you can't really clearly
quantify what fairness looks like that's
when explanations can help but that said
there are not many studies which
actually show what are the complementary
capabilities of explanations or model
interpretations in detecting such
unquantifiable Notions of what
unfairness looks like right so there is
again a big gap there and how does the
fairness the statistical Notions of
fairness of inherently interpretable
models compare with that of vanilla
models right so for example if I just
train an uninterpretable model you know
how does the fairness of that model
whether it's equality of opportunity or
whether it's statistical parity how does
how do those properties compare with the
fairness of a model that is inherently
interpretable either you know things
like rules or either when you're adding
prototype layers or attention weights
how to think about those right and are
there any inherent trade-offs between
certain kinds of model interpretability
and model fairness or do these aspects
like reinforce each other again that
relationship or connection is unclear
okay all right so privacy this is
actually something that has come up
during the break and I was talking to
somebody that I now can't recall but
essentially I think by definition a lot
of model interpretability and
explanations is about exposing
information about the model right so how
can these aspects or can these model
interpretations and explanations uh
expose sensitive information from the
data sets for example right uh again
there's very little research I think
buying a couple of papers there is not a
whole lot of work in this area so there
is very little research on the Privacy
implications of interpretable models or
explanations so what kinds of privacy
attacks are enabled by providing model
interpretations or explanations again we
don't have very clear answers right and
furthermore I mean we don't have answers
to that which means we also don't have
answers to this which is you know do
differentially private models actually
help defend against such attacks if so
under what conditions do they help
should we actually construct
differentially private explanations in
order to mitigate these kinds of attacks
these are all open problems
all right okay so the last part uh we
have thought quite a bit about you know
model interpretations explanations and
so on
um and we have sort of gone into the
depth of you know what their weaknesses
are how to think about these connections
all kinds of stuff right uh but and in
the process I mean while there are
limitations of these approaches there's
nothing that stops us from thinking
about new tools interfaces which can be
sort of used to make models uh more
interpretable or to facilitate model
understanding right so for example while
API is in commands and visualizations
are probably natural to some of us like
for example you know people who are
maybe more ml Savvy they may not be as
natural to say somebody like a policy
maker or a doctor so what can be some
new tools visualizations interfaces to
sort of help them understand what models
are doing right so that is also an
important area of research which I think
needs to receive more attention and of
course standardized benchmarks and tools
are also important for us to develop
some common understanding of like where
we are as a feet right
okay so the first question under this
broad direction that I put together is
can we construct more interactive
interfaces for end users to engage with
models right like instead of giving them
here is your lime explanation take your
future importances and this is what I
can give you what if we can make this
process more interactive what would be
the nature of such interactions right so
this is something that we have been
exploring with some students recently
sure like a quick demo hopefully that
should work let's see
so for example so this is basically a
tool that we developed called talk to
model
so you can use natural language
interface and chat with models like this
is literally like chatting with models
to understand how it's making
predictions right so for example what
are the predictions on people
over 20 years
okay so it's saying you know for data
with age greater than 20 the model is
predicting this and if I say explain
predictions
for people
over 20 years
it kind of shows me what are the
important features and so on right and I
can ask questions and so on and so forth
so this kind of interface is more
natural and the reason why we built such
an interface is that when we work with
hospitals and so on we often get a
request like a feature request from a
lot of these people that like the
current ways in which uml people give us
these tools is so clunky you will give
me five feature importance values and
you expect me to just deal with it like
I want a more natural way of engaging
with the model and one of the
practitioners we were interviewing once
was like I just want a natural way to
talk to the model right and from that is
uh born all this entire Endeavor but
okay so yeah I mean I'm not saying
that's perfect but like essentially we
need to keep thinking about more
interactive interfaces which can make
this process of understanding models
more natural right and
as model interpretations and
explanations are employed in different
settings we need to develop new
benchmarks and tools for enabling
comparison of various properties of
these uh explanation methods or
interpretation methods how do we sort of
enable that because I think we can't use
a single Benchmark for all possible
application settings so how do we make
the process of creating multiple
benchmarks easier so that's also
something we need to think about
okay so with that I think we are almost
coming to uh the end of this discussion
a little earlier than planned but I
think that's good I'm sure all of you
also want to take a break and go home
and do other things uh so there has been
a lot of renewed interest in model
understanding over the past half a
decade or so right and a lot of this has
come from this aspect of ml models being
deployed in a lot of healthcare and
other high-stakes settings right so
that's when because of that happening
there has been a growing interest in
seriousness in thinking about you know
let's understand models let's understand
the predictions they're making right and
as these models continue to get more and
more complex and they continue to find
more applications the need for
understanding what these models are
doing is only going to raise and I can
say that you know especially given the
legislations and regulations that are
also being pushed from different
quarters both in the Europe and U.S I
think the need for model understanding
is going to become a real requirement in
practice also in several domains
herbs as we just saw there are like
several interesting open research
problems and there are a ton of them and
what we just saw is probably a subset of
them but essentially the field is sort
of wide open to be explored and you know
sort of like open to be open to open for
us to basically develop a new
understanding of what we have today
where are the gaps and how to improve
right uh so the thing that I really like
about the field of explainable AI is
that you can approach this topic from a
lot of diverse perspectives whether
you're a theoretician whether you are an
ml algorithms person whether you're a
HCI researcher or an interdisciplinary
researcher there is definitely room to
contribute from all of these sites as
probably this discussion and the stock
is already convinced you right and in
fact I'm somebody who likes to sort of
move around some of these areas so I
feel like you know this area of
explainable AI is like a perfect ground
for somebody like me who likes to do
Theory develop methods and also do some
you know user studies and
interdisciplinary work I get to exercise
like different aspects of those
okay so with that I think I'm going to
pause here we are at 3 45 and I'm happy
to take more questions uh address any
other comments and so on
and oh before we do that so this is just
like a bunch of useful links uh course
on this topic a bunch more tutorials on
this topic and trustworthy ml initiative
also has a bunch more resources on this
topic